[Musik]
durch für diesen rasenmäher so crazy
oder herzlich willkommen hier heute zu
einem neuen blog meine damen und herren
alle hier sehe es bereits im titel
eingeblendet freunde wird es denn heute
etwas was ultras des jugendlich haben
amerikanische videos gesehen pro leuchte
medical berrys getestet haben
das sind so kleine sind schon richtig
gewähren also das hier ist diese
wunderbare und wenn man bei wikipedia
unter wirkung schaut sieht man schon das
glykoprotein verstärkt die wahrnehmung
der zunge für süßes auch saures oder
bittere schmeckt plötzlich süß habe ich
vor fünf wochen aus amerika bestellten
ist heute endlich angekommen im barry
michael fruth tablets experience
something to the amazing memories of
natural mit mate form der finest
selection of america avery und
gesellschaft der rückseite die notration
text alles einfach 0 aber fährt und cabo
halt wirklich von diesem aritkel berrys
werden wir heute testen das sind nicht
so viele hier drin das sind zehn stück
das krasse der ok-chef wird nicht süß
aber alles andere als andere geschmäcker
also seid wenn ich die zitrone essen
oder eine paprika oder so alles schmeckt
plötzlich so ist das halt judo und ich
fahre jetzt erstmal den supermarkt und
kaufen uns verschiedene früchte und
irgendwie sowas und ich bin gespannt
herzlich willkommen du dann mal wieder
im supermarkt und die eu an anders und
hier noch ganz ganz viel obst und gemüse
also leute es wird interessant wir sind
zurück zu hause angekommen und freunde
sieht so aus als würden wir eine die top
score machen man hat uns da einfach so
ein frosch ihren hingebracht ich zeige
euch ebenfalls wieder alles gekauft
haben als wir haben center schocks wir
haben zitrone zwiebel wir zwei tomaten
zwei verschiedene paprikas zwei
verschiedene äpfel an als mountain view
paloma ding fährt trinkt und saure sahne
und das essen wir alles mit michael
berry wir bereiten das jetzt vor und
dann sehen wir uns sofort wieder wir
haben jetzt hier alles gewaschen
sonst förderliche zitrone ananas bibel
mit von oben noch eine scheibe brot
geholt wir haben noch ketchup geholt und
drei löffeln und stellt diese meriten
wie verpackungen her mal aufgemacht wird
schon so sieht das ganze aus und das
hier sind die zehn pilger drin sin city
inside happy aus sie stehen ein paar
vorschläge mit was man das treffen
könnte
wir haben zum beispiel keine erdbeeren
gekauft haben keinen kredit aber gekauft
wir haben käse haben wir auch nicht
gesteht manchmal mit essig testen man
kann das mit kleinen gewürzgurken testen
also leute wenn ihr wollt dass wir werte
noch einen zweiten teil machen weil wir
haben zehn stückchen vom ersten mal
andere sachen dann lässt man fetten leid
da so sehen diese teile hause sind
wirklich aus wie solche reise brause
könnten hängt auch mit essen also wir
legen wir uns jetzt den mond und warten
bis sie aufgelöst ist
wir haben jetzt wirklich wenn ich ihm
auf dem tacho cook ist fünf bis sechs
minuten lang diesem aritkel berry in
unserem mund auflösen lassen und leute
wir fangen direkt an mit dem kompletten
klassiker zitrone die zitronen ausläuft
denke hält alle also leute wir haben
eine mögliche berry fünf bis sechs
minuten unserem und einwirken lassen und
angeblich soll das jetzt süß schmecken
das ist der moment auf den fünf wochen
gewartet haben
[Musik]
hettstedt megageil also es ist so die
perfekte mischung aus süß und sauer
megageil packungsbeilage standen dass
das nach einer halben stunde entlang
geht also ich würde sagen und waren
direkt weiter mit anderen lassen
alter ist das geil alter schwede
nein war was schmeckt alles wieso den
risiken und wir haben diese süßigkeiten
einfach ich bin echt nicht der riesen
aber scheiße schmeckt das teil alter ich
würde sagen als nächstes machen wir hier
weiter mit saurer sahne die wir uns
gekauft haben also auch seine leute ihr
wisst denkt wie schmeckt ich nehme meine
schönen großen löffel was schmeckt wie
jeder schmidt sowie joghurt alle
joghurteis mit vanille so ein bisschen
eine mal überlegt wie saure sahne sonst
schmeckt einfach weil er schmeckt wie
wenn ihr euch natur jugend kauf und da
einfach um mengen an zucker
reingeschüttet das heißt ich nicht
machen
das heißt es
ganz ehrlich ich habe gerade ein
bisschen bauchschmerzen weil wir haben
einfach unterhalten die drohne gegessen
drei stücken an ziemlich viele für saure
sahne gegessen allerdings machen wir als
nächstes den paprikas fest
[Musik]
das spiel zusammen mit nichts
vergleichen weiß wenn diese die
konsistenz einer paprika rettet aber
einfach so mit zucker gastronomen ich
probiere ich erst mal die rote paprika
die geldgeschäfte also paprika aber auch
probiert ich fand bisher wegner
krassesten saure sahne zitronen anders
als eigentlich alles bis auf die fabrik
auf die paprika schmecke zwar schon mega
heiß aber die anderen sachen wir auf
jeden fall noch besser als nächstes
kommt allerdings wirklich eine rohe
zwiebel
schon ziemlich weit weg war bei aspect
nur nach zwiebeln bestand aber auch das
ist bei den tatsachen überhaupt nicht
funktioniert das stelle treten gefällt
mir ist das haben wir hier paloma
vorbereitet stehen die sonne die mentale
great blutgetränkt es ist so süß es ist
einfach es ist ja ich kenne es nicht
dort aber es ist viel viel zu süß gerade
ich würde sagen auf die zwiebel
mittelstück alter das ich würde anders
allergan ja auch noch besser chance
rumliegen allerdings am ende machen
sondern als nächstes media eine tomate
[Musik]
schmecken ehrlich gesagt wie
tomatenketchup nur wie ein frischer
tomatenketchup nicht zu einer der so
abgepackt ist unrichtig im kino schmeckt
so unseren frischer tomatenketchup war
also bei obst und so das ist so
unfassbar kraft wenn eure eltern
beeindrucken wollte probst erst bei
seinem rücken barry ryan und rest
einfach zehn paprikas vorher dass mein
spiel viel zu kranken sie zusammen wie
jetzt bei apple gekauft einmal einen
roten und einen grünen die grünen sind
ja meistens bisschen dauer also cheers
mate
[Musik]
alles so kann alles er ist so unfassbar
kam die müsste porsche geht ist wie ein
apfel schmeckt so oder so sauer und
vielleicht die banken müssten zusammen
und bei maximaler ab sondern dass hier
schmeckt wie apfelsaft mit zucker
vergleicht man wissen wenn man fühlt
sich an wie sonnen obstgarten als jesus
hat er tatsächlich catcher vorbereitet
[Musik]
das schmeckt wie zucker tomatenketchup
alles was ist das hier ist alles viel zu
sehen alles was nicht so wie es schmeckt
oder normalerweise sei er hat jetzt
seinen süßen touch deshalb legen wie die
akha nahrung ist wenn ihr halt keine
alle versaue ist schmeckt jetzt süßen
alles was ich schon süß ist wie
beispielsweise das hier schmeckt einfach
so unmenschlich krank süß ich frage mich
was passieren würde wenn man jetzt
konkret essen würde weil so ein kletter
meiste aufsehen und sogar offen scheint
heute ist unhcr etwa noch nicht sind ob
das dann weiß dass meine als nächstes
haben wir mountain view vorbereiter der
akku darf auch nicht ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich weiß nicht genau wo sonst
schmeckt weil ich trinke aber hier
schmeckt das sehr sehr süß wenn man
gesund leben will vollkommen in ordnung
als selbst es getreten haben wir jetzt
hier eine orange ingwer und zitrone
cayennepfeffer ring also übels übels
gesund
geschmeckt im nachhinein schon auch sehr
schwaches da stand halt gerade bei
scharfe sachen ist es so dass wenn man
sie im mund harz als lachenmann wirklich
diesem berry hatte auflösen lassen dass
dort ein süß wird aber sobald im hals
hat mit schaf das hat mir immer noch
folgen genauso war es jetzt bei diesen
drink hier kommen wir nun allerdings und
brot freunde
wer ist einfach so pur brot also ich
wäre ich mich immer noch nur die
protonen und allerdings mit einer chance
berichtet zu also das schlimmste oder
juli wir müssen das aber im mund
wahrheit nicht draufhauen
[Musik]
darunter müssen natürlich mega süßes
ultra sie welchen orten tomaten
süßigkeiten bin lehrerin an der stelle
würde ich allerdings auch unsere michael
barratt ski-wm etwa ultra kraft wir
haben hier unfassbar viele dinge
ausgetestet ich glaube jetzt irgendwo
zehn verschiedene sachen
wenn ihr allerdings um vorschläge wie
beispielsweise hey probiert das noch mal
mit echo wir das mal mit gewürzgurken
mehr noch acht übrig dann schreibt uns
ihren vorschlag in den kommentaren
lasten like da einige stunden sind
vergangen
mein bauch fühlt sich an wie der zweite
weltkrieg es wichtig so eine gute idee
glaube ich so viele verschiedene sachen
durcheinander zu essen das hat zwar
alles mega lecker geschmeckt aber mir
ist echt schlecht auf jeden fall weil du
dich gerade noch chinesisch essen doch
waren wir auch zurück nach köln
eigentlich farbe gar nicht ich habe
einfach ebenso noch und schon sind wir
zurück in köln angekommen
übrigens als ich so fertig aus sehr aber
ich bin echt fertig landwirt klatscht
wenn ihr den block 500 juden ich fand
die mavericks auf jeden fall richtig
richtig heftig also es war halt wirklich
so dass wir sagen wäre gegessen haben
also diese tabletten und urplötzlich
schmeckt einfach eine zitronenlimonade
sarah schmeckt wie das süßeste nimmt
zwei bomben der welt das ist ja wirklich
todes heftig leute wenn ihr aber wollte
das thema nicht noch mehr verschiedene
lebensmittel und eventuell auch andere
getränke mit marica bestes
das sind noch mehr lebensmittel mit
münchen berlin und hessen an last gerne
mal like das schreibt uns in die
kommentare was für lebensmittel und
jetzt
[Musik]